Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Ich habe zum Einstimmen erstmal den
ältesten Java-Joke,
den ich gefunden habe.
Machen wir hier ein bisschen was
spannenderes.
Ja, so ist gut, ja.
Instant Legacy Code.
Also, ich muss euch warnen, ich habe keine Ahnung von Java und ich habe keine Ahnung von Spring Boot.
Aber.
Ich kann euch sagen,
warum ich Java
beziehungsweise Springwood lernen will.
Das ist der größte
World Tourist. Wieso?
Warum?
Ich meine, ich werde es ja sehen
und wahrscheinlich werde ich übelst rumflamen
gleich, weil es nicht ASP.NET Core ist.
Boah.
ist Springboot nicht der neueste Shit bei Java, wie man seine Anwendungen macht?
Dachte eigentlich, das ist so das, was da jeder verwendet.
Also ich weiß, bei uns auf der Arbeit zumindest ist das, glaube ich, zum größten Teil alles Springboot.
Ich mach mal kurz meine VM an.
Du arbeitest hauptberuflich, damit es kotzt dich an.
vielleicht kotzt es sich an weil du hauptberuflich damit arbeitest weil du
darin sachen machen muss die du nicht nicht gut findest und nicht spannend
findet
oder wird sich wird sich vielleicht weniger an kotzen stell dir vor du
guck mal packet tracer mittlerweile funktionieren immer noch nicht kacke stell dir vor du könntest
anstatt spring boot not jasper wenn du willst du weniger kotzen also ich wahrscheinlich nicht weil
ich mag noch erst für backendsachen überhaupt nicht noch erst ist für mich immer so ein
notwendiges übel wenn ich irgendwelchen frontend kram mache ich würde nie auf die idee kommen mit
ExpressJS irgendwelches JavaScript-Backend-Zeug zu machen.
Oder wird es dich weniger nerven, wenn du .NET C Sharp verwenden könntest mit ASP.NET Core?
Das würde mich persönlich weniger nerven, weil ich ASP.NET Core ziemlich nice finde.
Ja, wir machen das, wir machen das.
Also ich habe eine Sache schon gemacht.
Ich habe mir ein 5 Minuten Getting Started Tutorial angeguckt.
So ein 5 Minuten 30 Video auf YouTube.
Im Prinzip ging es da eigentlich nur darum, dass man IntelliJ verwenden soll.
das war es eigentlich das hier ist spring die seite habe ich auch schon gefunden aber angeblich
geht das über intelli j habe ich intelligenz ich habe immer intelligenter die keckweite
ich bin ja hier nicht eingeloggt
rissa toolbox app ich wies da gar nichts da geht es vielleicht immer intellij ultimate ich hoffe
dass jack dass ich hier schon mal weil ich habe ja das all desktop package spandell ich bin bloß
nicht eingeloggt ich hoffe der kommt mir jetzt nicht um die ecke mit sie müssen sich einloggen
oder sonstwas.
Fünf Streams
Streak. Pog.
Ich arbeite damit auch erst sechs Monate,
aber es ist überladen von Boilerplate Code.
Oh ja, da kann ich mir vorstellen, da ist ja
Java irgendwie bekannt für.
Also Dependency Injection im gewissen
Rahmen finde ich eigentlich ganz
nice. Also so
wie sie es in ASP.NET Core haben.
Man muss es aber auch nicht übertreiben.
Java.
Ja.
Ich kann euch auch erzählen, warum Java.
Wollt ihr wissen, warum Java?
Ist gar nicht so, dass ich jetzt gesagt habe, ich habe mal richtig Bock auf Java.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht.
So ein bisschen Bock, mir das mal anzugucken.
Zumindest mal so kurz.
Habe ich ja schon eine Weile.
Business Enterprise Developer.
Ja.
dafür werde ich nicht aber dafür brauchst du ja war das ist klar bis der centerpreis
stonks ist vieles in java kobold stream hat man auch schon das kann man kann ich die sachen aus
rider importieren und der check das also eigentlich nur die key maps der rest des rest brauche ich
nicht editor von toolbar notifizieren das ist gut das kannst du importieren
key maps importieren das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut
intelli j
ist es jetzt ultimate woran sieht man das ultimate edition ja sehr schön
Pogu.
Hast du Urlaub? Ich hab heute tatsächlich Urlaub, aber nur heute.
Nur heute. Ich war heute beim Hautarzt
und der hat mir
so einen ganz kleinen Leberfleck rausgeschnibbelt.
Nachdem das zu einer
irgendwie sehr unpassenden Uhrzeit war,
also quasi um 10,
da kannst du vorher nichts mehr machen und danach auch nichts mehr machen
und dementsprechend
hab ich den Tag Urlaub genommen.
Java Trace Logs sind auch die Hölle.
egal wir programmieren immer fehlerfrei da braucht man keinen die bar gegen keine
loks keine dokumentation keine kommentare und vor allem keine tests
easy
wieso nutzt du nicht eklips will ich mich selbst geißeln oder was eklips
aller
Eclipse
Wie hießen das andere Ding?
Es gab früher
Drei große Java-IDEs
Das war
Eclipse, ist ja das
Das uralteste schlechthin
Nach Eclipse, NetBeans
NetBeans, genau
NetBeans
NetBeans hatte ich früher mal installiert
weiß ich noch in meiner ausbildung net beans weil es dafür ich weiß gar nicht mehr was gab
es dann ein gutes python plugin damals für oder irgendwas aus irgendwelchen gründen die nicht java
waren hatte ich net beans installiert aber schon ewig her hast du tipps für mich wie ich sie schaap
lernen kann bin fiesi und habe basisprogramm also ich habe einen tipp für dich der ist zwar den gebe
ich immer der ist nicht so top aktuell aber es gibt ein kostenloses deutsches
buch das ist älter das ist von 2012 dementsprechend empfehle ich auch nur
noch die hälfte von dem buch aber von den basics her finde ich ist das eine
super einleitung zumal es kostenlos ist zwar war da mal kann man was trinken
Galileo Open Book C Sharp.
Das da.
Allerdings, also generell, die Grundlagen gelten ja immer noch.
Da fehlt mittlerweile einiges, was neu ist.
Aber in C Sharp ist ja nie so richtig was obsolet geworden.
ich würde mir das ganze angucken bis hier bis 16 du darfst dich alles quasi so als also gerade wenn
es hier geht hierbei nur die serialisieren es macht man nicht mehr xml kannst du auch vergessen
also nicht nicht alles was da drin steht ist wirklich auf dem top aktuellen stand weil das
von 2012 aber hier allgemein eine grundlage ist die sharp klassendesign vererbung polymorphism
wie es auf englisch was ist übrigens sind sie schafft so gar nicht gibt genau mit interface
ist nur delegates events strakt in am sling generics das ist nicht verkehrt soll ich dann
direkt wpf lernen wie gesagt nur bis nur bis 16 den rest kannst du das kannst du ignorieren
nur bis 16 inklusive 16 würde ich mir der pf kannst du knicken es sei denn du möchtest
windows desktop only anwendungen bauen und hast speziellen grund für wpf aber ansonsten
würde ich generell muss ich sagen so gut entwicklung
also mittlerweile bin ich der meinung warum nicht einfach einen embedded web server mit
der der den web interface mit ausliefert wenn man irgendwas wie mäßiges braucht
weil alles andere ist irgendwie kacke
also dass man meiner meinung nach beste cross-plattform desktop desktop cross
plattform wie framework was es gibt ist cute oder qt das problem dabei ist dass
du da früher oder später nicht an c++ vorbeikommt für mobile gibt es flatter für alles gibt es
elektron aber sieht schon dass alles irgendwie nichts geiles ja microsoft hat
es richtig verkackt die hätten
bist du dir sicher dass z++ geil ist
Naja, mich hat ja jemand letztens nach meinen Top 5 von 5 Programmiersprachen gefragt und da war ja auch C++ dabei.
Aber ich habe auch erklärt warum.
Weil auch eklige Sachen manchmal Spaß machen können.
Nicht weil C++ die geilste Sprache ist.
also gui sachen würde ich heutzutage gar nicht mehr machen einfach irgendein embedded web server
der website web web ausliefert und gut ist mit der feste fährst du besser als dich mit desktop
ui frameworks auseinanderzusetzen gibt es einfach nichts gescheites das hat microsoft wirklich
kolossal verkackt.
Die hätten die Chance gehabt,
einen Cross-Plattform-WPF zu machen.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich,
WPF ist halt auch irgendwie Schrott.
Ich mag WPF nicht.
Also,
wenn ich dieses XML-GUI-Gedöns
schon sehe, kriege ich Anfälle.
Ja, man könnte jetzt sagen, warum kriegst du bei WPF
XML Anfälle und HTML
ist okay. Ja gut,
HTML ergibt irgendwie noch Sinn.
WPF XML Gedöns ist einfach nur total doppelt gemoppelt und dreifach den gleichen Shit geschrieben
und überhaupt nicht selbsterklärend und ich, also dieses ganze XAML Zeug, das ist Schrott, ich mag das nicht.
Dann mach ich lieber HTML für irgendeine Webseite.
Und mit HTML und JavaScript hast du automatisch gleich ein Cross-Plattform-fähiges UI dabei.
Ja genau, Avalonia gibt es mittlerweile.
avalon ui das ist ja ein cross-plattform paket framework aber das halt nicht von microsoft selbst
aber trotzdem das ist ganz gut aber da hast halt auch die ganze geschichte und wie findest
es also ich finde es eklig ich habe hier eine ganz fettes wpf buch noch stehen irgendwo was
gar nicht, wo ich es hinhab. Das hat 1200
Seiten oder sowas. Das ist ein ultra fettes
WPF-Buch. Also ich hab mich damit auch
schon mal beschäftigt. Aber das ist noch WPF
von, hast du nicht gesehen, als es noch
neu und angesagt war.
Ja, und
also ich hab mich damit schon beschäftigt. Ich hab da auch
kleine Sachen mitgemacht, aber ich mag es
überhaupt nicht.
So.
Also, was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich machen?
Achso, wir müssen glaube ich noch Java-Zeug
überhaupt erst mal installieren, hä?
also gut wir haben das war package updates
bräuchte schon auf die 48 stunden was von 48 stunden woche ich freue mich schon drauf dass
das deutschlandticket wieder probleme macht und hoffentlich nicht abgeschafft wird aber
zumindest mal teurer wird ich kann es kaum erwarten ich hoffe wir kehren nie wieder
zurück zu diesem
Verkehrsverbund-Chaos.
Wie es
vor noch ein paar Jahren war.
Bei Eclipse hättest du das nicht machen müssen.
Warum? Du meinst, weil das
hätte Java als die...
Was hat das denn für Schmerzen, Mann?
Ist irgendwelche Mirrors, die kaputt sind?
Weil Eclipse das mitbringt, oder was?
Ich reboote nochmal.
Reboot.
Ach ja, während die Kiste rebootet, ich wollte euch ja erzählen...
Boah, der Reboot ging aber schnell, müsst ihr was sagen, oder?
Wie lange hat der Reboot jetzt gebraucht?
Acht Sekunden oder so?
Na ja.
Peppo ist am drücken.
Der bringt den Braunbär nach der Amstatt gerade.
So.
Also, ich wollte euch ja erzählen,
warum warum java machen macht kommen intel in jay in telly jay alt remade war schon mal auf
können wir jetzt gleich gleich loslegen wie gesagt ich habe keinen platzen schimmer sein
sieg gemacht haben wir fünf minuten quickstart things tutorial angeguckt und und das einzige
was mir davon so richtig gemerkt habe ist eigentlich benutzt intellij das hätte ich
aber auch so gemacht weil ich ja dass jetbrains all desktop package ab also
irgendwie muss man den kram ja auch mal benutzen
gucken wie groß ist eigentlich mein achten muss man gar nicht wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich ist die hälfte meiner festplatte ist wahrscheinlich voll mit
intellij idees jede idee ist bestimmt 8 gig oder so installiert habe ich hier
64 oder so haben wir
ähm
Gig nur für
IntelliJ Zeug oder sowas.
Ne.
Ne, warte mal. 6x8 ist nicht 64. Wie komme ich auf
64? 8x8 ist 64, ne?
6x8 ist 48.
48 Gig.
Ist aber immer noch viel.
So.
Also, was wollt ihr? Genau.
Ich wollte euch erzählen,
Storytime-Modus,
warum Java
und Java 25 nicht gerade
erst released. Kann man nachgucken,
was man für eine Java-Version hat?
Minus Version mit einem Minus ist bei Java,
glaub ich. 25.
Zack, guck mal hier. Pleading Edge.
Top aktuell sind wir wieder.
25.01
Genau, also warum Java?
Ich hatte gestern, also ich habe das schon eine Weile mir überlegt, hätte ich eigentlich mal Bock drauf mir anzugucken.
Aber jetzt erst recht, weil ich hatte gestern mit meinem Chef auf der Arbeit einen Termin.
Und da gab es so jährliche, wie nennt man das so, was es so für Förderungsmöglichkeiten gibt und so Karriereweg und so.
Und Fördergespräch, das gibt es einmal im Jahr bei uns.
So, und mein Chef hat mir erzählt, nee, nee, Mitarbeitergespräch habe ich ziemlich oft mit dem.
Nee, das ist so was, wo man auch das Zeug ausfüllen muss.
Das ist nicht so die Zieldefinition, die gibt es immer bei uns Anfang des Jahres.
Das ist so ein anderes jährliches Ding, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas mit Fördergespräch, frag mich nicht, ist auch egal.
So.
Und der hat mir erzählt, dass die jetzt quasi ein neues Programm, kann man es jetzt nicht wirklich nennen,
die haben so neue Leitlinien oder sowas für Leute in der IT und zwar ist denen aufgefallen, dass es besser ist, wenn Leute unzufrieden sind in ihrer aktuellen Position, ich versuche mal so die Kurzfassung,
Ja, denen ist aufgefallen, dass es besser ist, wenn Leute unzufrieden sind in ihrer aktuellen Position, wo sie sind und was sie machen, dann ist es besser, denen eine Alternative anzubieten innerhalb des gleichen Unternehmens, anstatt zu riskieren, dass die abhauen.
finde ich eigentlich eine gute Erkenntnis.
Oder?
Klingt auch irgendwie logisch.
Es sind ja gescheite Leute zum größten Teil,
dass man guckt, dass man die behält und denen vielleicht
was anderes gibt, wo sie mehr Bock drauf haben, anstatt
dass sie abhauen. Macht ja irgendwie Sinn.
Und im Zuge dessen
hat er mir eine
lange PowerPoint-Präsentation gezeigt.
Zumindest haben die jetzt
die Möglichkeit,
das konnte sie theoretisch vorher auch schon
machen, aber das ist jetzt quasi so
versicherungsweit, wie das Ganze
laufen soll und zwar kannst du jetzt dieses angebot nutzen aber du musst
nicht gleich das team wechseln so und ich habe ich wollte schon eine weile
mal zu unseren java entwicklern sommer für 14 tage oder sowas einfach
mal 14 tage ins wenn ich jetzt nach anwendungs entwickler team stimmt es
nicht da gibt es ja einige aber ich sage jetzt aber weil so zu unseren
anwendungsentwicklern zu unseren anwendungsentwicklern und dort gibt es
auch ein eigenes der fordsteam warum es das bei uns nicht gibt keine ahnung für
bei uns wird fast schon mehr dazu passen weil das was wir machen ist ja eigentlich
90 prozent überschneidung damit aber wurscht und da wollte ich war für 14
tage hin und ich habe mir gedacht das ist ja business enterprise und ich weiß
dass die filial war machen da ist es bestimmt nicht verkehrt wenn ich mal ein bisschen wenigstens
ahnung habe von java und spring weil ich weiß oder spring boot sagen was spring was was spring
ohne boot was bringt nicht mal dieses dieses komische framework von java das ganz alte hieß
das nicht so das war so ein bisschen schwarz und weiß und super hässlich aussah oder oder
Oder hieß das anders?
Swing! Ach, Swing war das nicht.
Spring. Swing.
Ja, siehste, ich hab von Java
keine Ahnung. Aber ihr habt recht, Chat.
Swing. Genau.
Und deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht, ich guck mir einfach mal ein bisschen Java an.
Und was
gibt es Besseres, um seine Java
Skills zu üben,
wie kekws
Service
in Java neu programmieren?
keck vs service ist ja prinzipiell schon mal die beste web anwendung aller zeiten
nicht wegen swing wegen spring schaue ich mir spring boot schaue ich mir ja war an
ich schaue mir ja war eigentlich an und springen dass ich mich auskennen wenn ich
mal 14 tage zu unseren anwendungsentwicklern gehe ich habe das aber noch gar nicht offiziell
eingetütet oder sonst was aber wer schon mal nicht verkehrt war ein bisschen plan davon hat
oder dass man aber was machen kann ja kek wie es das service ist wirklich hier world first high
iq web service was das macht ist ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich das ding hier noch irgendwo
laufen habe kek wie es das service guck mal weg wie wie gibt es nicht ich habe kein kek wie es
service geklont was soll das denn jetzt clown keck wss ups das ist eine dotnet web anwendung
mit irgendwelchen enzimel terraformen gedöns wo wir jetzt nach sachen aufbaut das brauche
heute nicht ich starte das mal ich hoffe ich kann das überhaupt starten mein dotnet ist so
neu und das projekt so alt und hier dort mit ran probieren aus
überhaupt funs
na ja ich installiere sich dort nennt aber kann ich nicht einfach moment kann
ich nicht einfach sagen nicht programm cs wissen das ding ja
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen, das ist ein .NET 9 Projekt?
Und dann geht's einfach?
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ja, Funst, easy.
Also was CAC WSService macht, ist folgendes.
Das rotiert random einfach dieses Bild, okay?
Wenn man auf die Webseite, wenn man auf den Endpunkt geht.
Mehr macht das nicht.
Aber das ist eine super Anwendung
Um so neue Sachen
Um so neue Sachen zu üben
Ja
Da muss man ein bisschen Java basteln
Da muss man ein bisschen
Web-Anwendungen sich anwenden
Da sind wahrscheinlich am Ende
40 Zeilen oder so
So und man kann
Da lernt man nämlich auch wie man Parameter
Übergibt
Man kann hier hinten nämlich auch irgendwie dran
Fragt mich nicht Rotate oder so
äh, ne
ähm, lass mich mal kurz gucken
guck mal, damals hatte
C-Sharp noch eine Main-Methode
gibt's ja heute auch nicht mehr, also gibt's schon, aber
da, Startup
JS gab's da noch, keck
Controller, das ist ein MVC-Projekt
noch, mal gucken wie das
in Spring ist
ähm, so, und man kann
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann man auch
Slash Kokona machen
Was auch immer das macht
Das macht genau das gleiche
Okay
Hatten wir nicht irgendwo einen Parameter?
Chat ich war mir eigentlich relativ sicher
Ach ne hier
Hier man kann direkt hinten den Parameter angeben
Okay
Was
So
Man kann
Man kann direkt sagen hier 180
Ja dann dreht er
Okay 1
genau, ja, ja, so ging das
ja, und das bauen wir jetzt einfach mal
in Spring Boot nach, also einfach
ist schnell gesagt, ne
ich hab absolut keinen blassen Schimmer davon
dann machen wir mal hier
Spring Boot Champ
so, auf geht's
ich hoffe mal, IntelliJ
guidet uns da ein bisschen
wie das funktioniert weil wie gesagt absolut keinen plan ich kann ja war lesen ja ich kann
auch ein paar zeilen java zu schreiben aber ich habe also noch nie großartig was damit
gemacht und mit spring gut noch gar nicht kennst du kurs das sich im view js ui framework
hat intellij auch integration ja das ganze jetbrains zeug hat integration ich benutze
das nicht ich benutze nur die lokale ab und zu mal zum auto komplett von kleinem zeug und sonst
Okay, neues Projekt.
Also, laut dem Tutorial, was ich im Internet gesehen habe, kann IntelliJ...
Habe ich das richtige IntelliJ installiert?
laut dem Tutorial, was ich gesehen habe, kann
IntelliJ Spring Boot
Ah ne, ja ich hab's richtige.
Hast du schon mal ein Gemini
CLI getestet? Ne.
Angeblich kann
IntelliJ Spring Boot
Anwendungen generieren. Vielleicht muss man hier
mehr sagen via Plugin?
Das ist Ultimate!
das ist ultimate
sie ist ja hier ich habe nur ich habe ich habe nur ultimate installiert und gar nicht gar nicht
community
manage plugins und war irgendwie spring oder so
sollte das jetzt nicht irgendeinen text laden vielleicht daneben
Weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin, oder was?
Das ist ja doof.
Ne, aber das ist doch was anderes, oder?
Ne, aber das ist Spring Ultimate.
Wir brauchen Spring Boot Ultimate.
Ja gut, dann logge ich mich halt mal ein schnell.
Spring.io Webseite, nee ich will schon, weil da geht bestimmt auch die ganze Integration
mit Spring Boot und so in IntelliJ net richtig.
Ich weiß, ich kenne die Webseite hier, Dista.
Aber dann hast du bestimmt auch Probleme mit Package-Management da drinnen und sonst was, wenn das nicht geht.
Geht? Na gut, dann machen wir das mal.
Also, probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Quickstart.
Startspring.io, das meint ihr, oder?
So, also, was wollen wir haben?
Sprache, Java.
Projekt.
Cradle, Groovy.
Bonk, HS, Alter.
In Groovy habe ich mal was für
Confluence entwickelt.
Das war ganz
abartig.
Kotlin machen wir heute nicht.
Wir müssen mal Maven
nehmen.
Das ist bei VMware
mittlerweile.
Tanzu ist das
VMware Kubernetes.
Okay, Maven.
Maven kenne ich. Das ist wenigstens was, was ich schon mal gehört habe.
Wir wollen die neueste Version, würde ich sagen.
Was ist denn die neueste Version? 3.5.5?
Alternativ gibt es auch 4.0.0 M2.
Milestone, hä? Milestone 2?
Chat, geblieben, aber 3.5.5, da findet man auch mehr Hilfe.
Krupp. Krupp ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie eine Namespace, oder?
also machen wir hier einfach irgendwie wo blos punkt w das ist ja ein umgedrehter
schreibweise keck keck w.wog los okay artefakt und name demo weg wie schreibt man das große
oder klein?
Pack WS
Service.
Wollen wir eine andere Score machen?
Description. Null.
Jar kenne ich,
Var kenne ich nicht.
Macht man Camel Case nicht mit anderen?
Also das ist quasi...
Ne, ich mache das jetzt so. Fertig.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was denn Var ist
überhaupt.
So und Java 17125.
Die Pendancies lassen wir mal.
Können wir dann bestimmt auch über IntelliJ hinzufügen.
Jetzt sagen wir Generate.
Pack W erste Service wird runter.
Moment, was? Nur 15 KB?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist bestimmt wie bei Node.js.
Da ist bestimmt nur ein Package.json drin.
und wenn ich erst mal installieren dann sind es am ende drei gigabyte weil vielleicht nicht
ganz so krass wie bei der nots anwendung der witter das halbe internet runtergeladen
downloads wie ich ist das ding jetzt noch mal spring
service okay
keck
wie zeug sich da drin ab
keck vs service zip
unzip keck vs service
zack
da sind wir
ok dann machen wir mal
intellij auf hier
home max repos
spring
irgendwas hab ich doch genau
hab ich doch
bin ich nicht in repos
ach
Da soll es hin.
Hä?
Jetzt auch doch.
Er checkt es wieder nicht.
Muss mal refreshen.
Will er mich verarschen?
Der ist es doch
Hier, da, da ist es
Will er nicht, hat er keinen Bock
Nope
Ach, das machen wir nicht
Bam
IntelliJ neu starten
intelligent startet nicht mehr
doch okay
also repos spring kann er tippen leute da ist es doch spring boot camp
kqs service ok perfekt so open trust
so was haben wir denn hier jetzt wir haben dann geht repo ok help markdown
juckt mich nett xml ja ich checke nicht warum die alle so auf xml sachen stehen
Da hat übrigens meine Schrift und Theme und so hat er gar nicht übernommen.
Sieht ganz verkehrt aus.
Warum die so auf XML stehen, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber in .NET ist das Projekt witzigerweise auch XML.
So, dann haben wir hier Maven.
Rapper.
Was auch immer.
Wenn man den Maven Wrapper macht.
Source.
Test.
Errorless Programming.
Brauchen wir keine Tests.
Resources.
Java.
Kek WS Service Application.
Und wo ist jetzt mein Main.
Punkt Java oder sowas.
Ist das das hier?
Ah ja.
Project JDK is not defined.
Uiuiui.
Kann ich einfach das hier nehmen?
Wahrscheinlich, ja
Gehen wir jetzt einfach
Das obere, zack
Okay, scheint zu gehen
So, also er hat Schriftart und so hat er schon mal nicht übernommen
Das müssen wir jetzt gleich mal
Font
Ähm
What
Font Size
settings pons erin's
er von jetpens mono wollen wir doch gar nicht wollen hack irgendwie 16 oder so
noch ein bisschen was sie doch vielleicht sogar 17 16
dann erkennt man wenigstens was so und als team eigentlich mein auge
flashback
xml java auch auf 25 müsste eigentlich sein weil ich 25 in diesem generator ausgewählt
hab. Dracula.
Moment.
Das ist Theme für...
Das ist
Theme für den...
Für die ganze Idee.
Ich bin jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen verwirrt.
Na gut, ich meine, das geht ja so auch.
Gibt Schlimmeres.
Okay, also was habe ich hier?
Das ist...
Okay, hier ist der Start von dem Ganzen.
Okay, dann launch ich das jetzt mal.
Wie launcht man das eigentlich gescheit?
Spring Boot.
Was ist das?
Maven Way.
CMD?
Oh!
Batch!
monka giga
in den eintracht
das habe ich eigentlich
gesucht
editor
color skill
light
hätte gerne das wishlist studio team irgendwie finde ich das von den farben
ja aber wir lassen das jetzt ist schon schon okay so was bin ich hier sehend
wir sollten uns glaube ich mal das quick quick start hier angucken
quick start start new project das haben wir gemacht
add your code das machen wir nicht ich will einfach nur wissen wie man startet
doch ich kann wahrscheinlich hier ich will ich mache das in .net auch nie
über über das eingebaute dinge in der idee ich starte das immer über cli
vielleicht ist es aber ein jahr war besser als über die idee zu machen keine ahnung
Aha, Punkt Slash, Cradle haben wir nicht, also machen wir Punkt Slash Mvv.
Ich habe was falsch gemacht.
Achso, Boot Run muss ich machen.
Okay.
Ne, geht immer noch nicht.
Was?
Du musst eine fähige Lebenszeitphase spezifizieren.
ja also das beispiel von schon einmal
was will er eigentlich von mir ich will nicht das full stack trace bin ich im
falschen ordner vielleicht
Okay, was ist, wenn ich jetzt hier drüber starte?
Wie, hier findest du das?
Ah.
Das ist jetzt, das hat jetzt gestartet.
aber es ist nichts passiert.
Ich paste jetzt wirklich mal den Kram hier rein.
Ist halt fertig. Sollte er nicht einen Webserver starten?
Ich paste mal das hier rein jetzt.
Äh.
Du hast die Dependency nicht hinzugefügt.
Ich habe das hier durchgeklickt.
Ach.
Ha.
Okay.
Okay, wie macht man in IntelliJ Dependency Management?
Hier wahrscheinlich irgendwo drin.
Dependencies.
gibt es da nicht so was also in rider würde ich jetzt nougat aufmachen
hat er nicht so was wie dependencies kann man das nicht kann man nicht irgendwie sagen
at dependency oder so was muss man das da von hand machen da kommt ja auch ein maven knopf
Aber das macht ja nichts hier.
Oder Kamera?
Dependencies?
Ich will ja neue hinzufügen!
Plus?
Ne, add maven projects.
Ich bin überrascht, wie kompliziert man sowas machen kann.
Ich will die Webdependency.
Wie zum Teufel füge ich...
Also Chat, ich bin geneigt dazu, mich tatsächlich mal bei Jetbrains einzuloggen.
Maven Plungins wäre das was wie wo.
Hier?
Ich will die Pendancies hinzufügen und zwar die da hier.
Die, die.
Gibt es denn?
Du editierst von Hand die POP-XML.
Ja gut, aber woher weißt du denn, was da rein muss?
Gibt es quasi sowas wie hier Maven Package Search Central?
Ja, Moment, ich habe das ja nicht aktiviert.
Vielleicht liegt das daran, dass ich eben keine richtig echte IntelliJ-Ultimate habe.
Central.
Das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Was?
Alt-Insert.
Insert.
Okay, das können wir anderweitig machen.
Wir können jetzt hier...
Ah!
Ah! Okay.
Dependency.
Nicht so was wie Spring Web.
Sollte der jetzt nicht irgendwas finden?
Jetzt?
was was brauche ich hier starter web oder irgendwas was okay ist
was hat doch irgendwas spring boot start aber warum finde ich das und findet man das hier nicht drin
verstehe ich nicht müsste das ist oder search for
Manage Dependency vielleicht?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Da bin ich zu blöd für,
dass es da drüber...
Ah, hier, das da.
End of Life Security Fix Available.
Sollte man das nicht mehr benutzen?
Hä?
Doch, oder?
Ja, ne, bei mir sucht er nix.
Also der...
Wenn ich da drinnen nach Web suche,
findet er nix.
Dependency Web.
Guck, der findet nix.
Ne.
ok also ich brauche das hier ja die pendens ist aber ich will ich moment
nicht vier was was hatte ich noch mal für eine 355
gefühl ist ein bisschen hakelig an copy
so
ok
jetzt hier nicht in den knopf
was das zirkel changes aha
Okay, und jetzt habe ich hier Webgedöns am Start.
Das ist sehr nice.
Das heißt, jetzt kann ich hier hingehen und...
So.
Ach, jetzt kann ich es importieren.
Und hier, guckt.
Request.
Alles klar.
Hier, import.
Import.
Okay, was ist, wenn ich es jetzt starte?
Ha!
Startet on Port 8080.
Wo muss ich jetzt slash hello?
Äh.
Ups.
War nicht slash hello?
Ach, muss ich irgendwas noch angeben?
controller tag nehmen wo sich nicht hier oben
ok
restart gibt es dann control f5 stop entweder
was 80 80 slash hallo
chat es fronzt massive spring boot stellt ok
eckermann modus aktiviert
so genau das reicht so ok und jetzt
als seniorentwickler mindestens mindestens
Ich finde ich die Syntax ein bisschen komisch. Warum schreibt man ein Request? Na gut.
Also in .NET würde das so aussehen.
Also was gibt es da anscheinend nicht? Parameter.
gemacht macht irgendwie sinn so alles wir brauchen jetzt wir brauchen jetzt
für die index seite also get mapping slash nennen wir es mal ja weg weh anscheinend
ist es in Java so, dass man
Methodennamen klein schreibt. Kann das sein?
Also man würde so CamelCase dann schreiben.
So, StringName.
Name.
Ach, warte mal. Moment, Moment.
Muss ich jetzt...
Muss man das so machen? Name gleich
Lull?
Nee.
Wo kommt das jetzt her?
request parameter aber aber ich habe doch gesagt neben gleich
kann jemand sagen warum man dann etwas davor schreibt weil ja war das so will weil nur dann
sind das an den leben wie heißt das bei java das ist keine das ist kein label
auch keine kein attribut das ist ein annotation
also das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau was dafür schmerzen hat hier
egal
Moment, warum geht Hello jetzt gar nicht mehr?
Was?
Achso, bin ich doof.
Ich hab's doch...
Name gleich.
Okay, Funst.
Gut.
So, und da wollen wir jetzt nicht
Hello ausliefern,
sondern unser Keckweh-Image.
Wie kriegen wir das hin?
Wir brauchen erstmal unser Bild.
das kann man uns hier erholen keck ws service ob www root oder wo habe ich das licht
ich habe doch da eine neue version gebaut dass das
das ging doch das haben wir doch überhaupt nicht mehr so gemacht
das haben wir überhaupt nicht mehr so gemacht
weil hier hatte ich die ganzen dinge vor vor gerendert quasi
drinnen in jeder in jeder x beliebigen variante ja aber wir hatten doch dann
später so eine image library die das automatisch alles gedreht hat bin ich
jetzt total hängen geblieben wo habe ich das
ich will direkt eine image response haben
Wenn ich das Zeug mal ordentlich nennen würde, dann würde ich vielleicht auch wiederfinden.
Was haben wir hier?
Programm CS.
Nice, das ist das Beste.
Das ist unbedingt wichtig, da ich dafür ein Projekt angelegt habe.
Ja, dann weiß ich gerade nicht.
Aber ich weiß genau, dass wir das schon mal anders gebaut haben.
Ist aber auch egal.
Können wir jetzt ja in Java so machen.
also hier will ich jetzt ein bild ausliefern immer mal dieses bild so
lassen wir das einfach mal nur ein bild ausliefern safe image es keck wp ng
das gibt schon
überhaupt nicht so jetzt ist die preisfrage wie kriegen wir denn überhaupt wir brauchen
sowas wie www root aber vielleicht in die vielleicht ressorts moment wir gucken jetzt
mal spring gut index html
mvc spring
Na gut.
Ich meine, wir können das Bild doch einfach hier hinschmeißen, oder?
Können wir nicht sagen hier?
Downloads.
Cake W.
Ist es?
Dann machen wir jetzt hier einfach mal irgendwie noch eine, ich weiß keine Ahnung, ob ich das nennen soll.
Directory.
Ich nenn's mal www-Root, da weiß ich
wenigstens, was damit gemeint ist.
Jetzt packen wir da kek-w rein.
So.
Oh nu? Okay.
Jetzt wird's kompliziert.
Jetzt will ich so was
wie File Open.
Da hören erst mal
meine Java-Skills auf, ja?
Java Read File.
Da müssen wir uns jetzt durch...
Da müssen wir uns jetzt durchgoogeln.
Ich will nicht ASCII...
Buffered Read...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Java Read Binary File.
Read Binary Files in Java.
Warum ist hier eigentlich...
Warum ist hier eigentlich so voll...
Warum...
Warum lacht der Chat schon?
Ist das was total Abwegiges,
was ich hier vorhabe, oder wie?
datei öffnet in java. he doesn't know he lacks critical information. file input stream
file output stream. image io das klingt gut. java image io. image reader
image wap da pack ich will einfach einen beiz ich will einfach beiz haben und dann als meinem
type image ja fein wieder all beiz so was so was habe ich mir gedacht aber es gibt es ja anscheinend
Moment, java read file as byte array. Wir fragen jetzt chatgpt.
Ja genau, das will ich haben. What the hell? Was zum? File input stream. Das ist gut.
Was? Read?
Ach, Files gibt's.
Ach so.
Ha!
Ja, das ist ja nice.
Sowas hab ich gesucht.
Read all bytes.
Genau. So.
Punkt Slash
www.root
Slash
kq.png
Okay, das geht so schon mal auf gar keinen Fall.
Warum?
Path?
Oder bestimmt New, hä?
Java-Stells.
U-Path.
What?
Was?
Was hat der mir gerade alles
generiert, Mann?
Was?
Alter.
Was hat der denn hier alles generiert?
Mann, hör mal auf.
path of off chat hat recht auf
jeder wehmer noch nicht
anhändelt except
exception da muss ich so eine art try drive try catch oder sowas machen
was da gibt es neben braun so war es so was muss ich da machen
da wir gucken uns mal wir gucken uns mal ein example an die das leute machen die wissen wie
java funktioniert.
Okay, kommt
eine ByteArray raus. Das dachte ich mir schon.
Mein PathGet.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen
PathOf und PathGet?
Gibt's keine Hilfe.
IPathFactoryManager
Singleton.
ist genau das gleiche oder path get und read all by und und und path of
okay also hier so guck mal so machen wir das doch
try catch io ah ok man catch nur io exceptions
und dann wird einfach nur gecatcht mit einem system error ja
Davon wird die Exception
geht die aber auch nicht weg, wenn ich die einfach nur printe
Daher kommt das wahrscheinlich
dass wenn man eine Java Anwendung startet
das Ding erstmal 500 Exceptions auf der Konsole auswirft
aber es dann trotzdem läuft
Warum muss ich das überhaupt catchen?
Ganz blöde Frage
Warum muss ich das catchen?
Warum kann ich es nicht einfach lassen und dass es knallt?
Es kann doch einfach knallen
Dann ist doch gut, wenn es knallt
also hier muss er nur exception
ach komm wir lassen wir machen was ist das für hat moment moment wie macht man eigentlich ich
glaube system out oder system out dass da fehler beim lesen der png ja genau das brauchen wir kann
java eigentlich so was 0 w doppelpunkt und int ja war sowas ja war interpoliert strings
String Interpolation in Java.
Nee.
String Format macht man da.
Ja, aber das ist auch eklig.
Okay, ich tippe mal einfach.
Das gibt's nicht.
Ja, sowas Modernes aber auch.
Wie kann es sowas geben?
man muss Format Strings machen
nein
ich weiß
ja nicht
dann machen wir es halt so hier
genauso wie die Dudes das hier
in dem Beispiel gemacht haben
so und jetzt haben wir hier
das ganze Ding
Read All Bytes
aha
Print Stack Trace
bricht das auch...
Ah, das ist gut. Das bricht bestimmt auch das
Programm auch gleich ab, oder?
Should be
Macht's nicht?
Kann ich mir das auch sparen?
Ist eine alte
Sprache? Naja, aber
macht mir da immer noch was dran.
also C Sharp hatte das beispielsweise auch nicht von Anfang an
und sogar in Python gibt es jetzt
neue F-Strings
habt ihr das gesehen?
das ist eigentlich auch ganz cool
da hat ja fast schon
wenn man sagt C++ bessere String-Formatting
und das heißt schon was
String-Templates zeige ich mal her
warum gibt es da nicht
Playungen? Ach ne, Bildung
nicht Playungen
Okay, es geht nicht, anscheinend.
Was?
Alter, kann man es noch komplizierter machen?
What the fuck?
naja, aber so geht das ja auch
so, jetzt haben wir das Bild gelesen
und jetzt ist die große Preisfrage
wie setze ich
den Type, weil ich will ja kein
String returnen
ich will eigentlich Bytes
returnen
aber das geht ja wahrscheinlich so nicht
ähm, ich will
vor allem will ich
in meinem Type setzen
so, Response.
content type oder sowas dann gucken wir mal hier spring return image png
das juss
und du hast es vor ort
response body
spongebob
warum muss hier warum muss hier einfach random was rein geht
Also ByteArray ist schon mal richtig.
Ah, man kann gleich sagen,
hier Throws.io Exception.
Get Resource as Stream.
ByteArray.
Was ist denn das? Das ist ja noch besser als
das, was ich hier hatte.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Das finde ich auch. Da kann ich mir das Try-Catch
sparen.
Bietet das eigentlich IntelliJ auch an?
Add Exception to Method Signature.
Ah ja, das ist gut.
Das finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Wisst ihr, das finde ich gar nicht so übel.
Dann weißt du wenigstens, was da drin nicht behandelt wird und was da rauskommen kann an Exceptions.
Ich könnte mir allerdings vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen abartig wird, wenn du viele Sachen verwendest,
weil die babbeln sich ja so hoch, die Exceptions.
irgendwann hast du dann am ende 80 dinge oder so stehen
du musst dein index html ich habe kein index html
ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht mit den mit mit wie auch immer man das hier
nennt mit diesen dieser thrower annotation da hinten dran bin ich gar nicht übel zum recht
überlegt so und wie machen wie macht der du dir das jetzt get restore input stream get class
Was?
Ach, get resource as stream.
Ach, das ist, wenn es embedded ist, oder?
Das ist ein bisschen sowas wie, ja, halt so die embedded resources, die es auch in .NET gibt.
Ich will es ja vom Filesystem lesen, dann ist das hier eigentlich richtig.
Was haben wir dann hier sonst noch?
I.O. Utils.
To bite a ray.
Ah.
Nö.
Gibt's nicht.
Oder nicht.
Aber ich hab das ja schon als bite a ray.
Also.
Gibt es in Java sowas hier oder sowas hier?
Äh.
Reiz.
Ah ja.
Ist das verpönt in Java?
Ist verpönt.
Warum gibt's das denn dann?
Ach, Kunst gibt's auch.
Nee, geht aber nicht.
Kunst war...
Nee.
Wegen Leuten wie mir.
Wie? Was kann ich dafür?
Das Final.
Final War.
Jetzt wird es aber abgedreht.
Das heißt, jetzt ist Bites
Read Only, oder wie?
also ich bin das von C Sharp gewöhnt, da nimmst du für alles wahr und letztendlich bleibt es ja
trotzdem stark typisiert ja also hier kommt ein Byte Array zurück das heißt Byte ist jetzt ein
Byte Array. Wenn ich das hier eingebe sagt er das bestimmt auch. Byte Array, ja dann machen wir das
so. So und jetzt returne ich die Bytes. So und das soll es jetzt, was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Achso, ja, ich kann das so returnen. Ich muss ja dann noch ein bisschen was dazwischen machen. So,
restart. Machen wir mal, komm wir machen mal hier einen Chrome auf. Und das machen wir mal weg.
Aber hier so, localhost port 8080. Achso, meinem Type muss ich noch setzen. Der denkt ja immer
noch dass das text ist muss ich ist dafür vielleicht das response body zuständig
media type image jpeg ja aber wie mache ich das
Ach hier.
What?
Ach, in das Mapping schreibt man...
Okay, das ist schon weird, Champ.
In das Mapping.
Ja, da hätte ich jetzt wirklich nicht dran gedacht.
Das ist schon irgendwie
Man kann nicht sagen
eklig
Aber schon irgendwie
Merkwürdig
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr
Jetzt ist es kaputt
Media Type erstmal importieren
Value muss ich das jetzt value nennen?
Value gleich
an die path okay
das will ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so schön aber mein ja auch
man gewöhnt sich daran okay jetzt da ist es leute
keck ws service
kann so live looks good to me schippet das ist korrekt ich habe einen png und
kein jpg aber der browser ist schlau genug der check das anhand vom header wahrscheinlich
image png value also da muss ich sagen
Ich weiß gar nicht wollte sagen da finde ich es in asp.net schöner gelöst aber ich weiß
Es ist auch da ein bisschen painst champ da musste dann sagen return new
Irgendwas content by content oder irgendwie sowas
Muss ich auch immer gucken wie das da funktioniert
Kannst du alt text anzeigen lassen
Keiner gibt es nicht gibt kein alt text
Das ist nicht...
Wie heißt das?
Accessibility?
Regelt?
Okay, aber das ist schon mal gut.
Das hier unten können wir übrigens minimieren.
So, und jetzt...
Keine Barrierefreiheit auf Deutsch, genau.
Und jetzt kommt die große Preisfrage. Wie rotieren wir in Java ein PNG?
action result ist bei mbc bei
minimal apis ist es glaube ich da kannst du mittlerweile irgendwie sagen return und dann
gibt es verschiedene contents oder kannst du ich weiß nicht ob es wie ob spite content war ich
weiß aus dem kopf gar nicht da muss ich auch immer nachgucken aber das geht jetzt anders
als noch zu mbc zeiten so wie rotieren werden bild da brauchen wir jetzt eine
image library vielleicht hat ja war ja sowas vielleicht hat ja war ja schon so
was in der standard library trainer java rotate image guck mal java rotating vor
13 jahre swing nicht wirklich
java rotate png image
auto rotate image with java
Ach so, meinst du das?
Ja, du hast recht, man könnte das auch über CSS lösen, aber das will ich ja nicht.
Ich will ja mal gucken, wie man das Backend-mäßig macht.
Java AWT Image.
And the Java Image IOPack.
Haben wir Image, hab ich Image ION nicht, hat er das?
Gibt's doch hier Java X Image ION, es ist doch schon da.
Einfach das beide Ray rotieren
Ja, da kommt bestimmt genau das
Richtige raus
Was bin ich hier sehend
Okay
Da kann man direkt
Das ist gar nicht schlecht
von...
Kann man da nicht direkt von einem Fad lesen?
Wahrscheinlich so, ha?
Nee, das geht mal wieder nicht.
Also Image.io.
Image.io.
Oh.
Ja.
image.io.read.input.file.
Ach, so geht das.
Ja, das ist doch auch gut.
Das finde ich nice. Das gefällt mir.
Machen wir das hier mal weg.
War.
Keg.wait.
File.
Jawoll. Buffert.image.
Image, Image, Read, Buffered Image, war, null.
So, und jetzt die Fine Rotation Angle, Math to...
Was? Moment, was, wie, wo, ah, Moment, was zum...
Jetzt, jetzt, das wäre ja auch deutlich zu einfach, wenn man jetzt sowas sagen könnte wie Rotate oder so, das geht natürlich nicht.
das wäre deutlich zu easy
okay wir machen das war einfach das beispiel durch so das hier muss dann eigentlich noch
vom paar parameter aber das müssen wir gucken wie wir das hier rein kriegen also anstatt
name ich will ja eigentlich über das machen 90 90 grad soll das rotiert werden so dann
braucht man ein was er fein transform translate image to keep it all da
das ist das top das ist advanced ist der image rotierten weil ich hier gesehen habe ich habe
Miss war
New with
Ich will new with old with sein
Was durch zwei
Warum durch zwei ich will es einfach nur täten ja genau ich will es einfach nur das will ich nichts machen
einfach nur rotiert ist es kann das ding aber auch so
acht damit der um center rotated ach so mal gucken was das ohne macht
und warum muss ich jetzt ich will mal wissen was passiert wenn ich wenn es einfach nur so macht
Natürlich war only.
Sonst.
So, und jetzt create output image.
New.
What the fuck?
Was zum?
Moment, ich dachte, ich hab das Image schon
Rotated
Ich hab das noch gar nicht rotated
Morgen KS
Moment, Moment
Das finde ich so abartig, gibt's da nicht eine ordentliche Library
Für Chatgear, ihr habt doch vorhin
Irgendwas geschrieben
Irgendjemand hat doch vorhin was hier
Geschrieben mit Image.io oder
Ich kann das einfach kopieren, aber ich finde das super
Ah, hier the complete code
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Hier the complete code, easy
Flop
So, easy
Wir klauen das uns einfach
Jetzt können wir mal der Gelegenheit auch gerade mal gucken
Wir machen hier private
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das in Java funzt
Private
tja jetzt kriegen wir dann beide ray wahrscheinlich zurück keine ahnung generate image
und machen wir einfach so sich umford oder sowas
wieso machst du das sind ja war stimmt da war es noch gar nicht da wo ich das erzählt habe ich
Ich mache bei uns auf der Arbeit demnächst ein Praktikum bei den Entwicklern.
Dachte mir ein bisschen Java zu können, ist nicht verkehrt.
14 Tage.
Dachte mir ein bisschen Java angucken, im Vorfeld schadet ja nichts.
Ja.
Also ne, Praktikum, das heißt halt so.
ich mache nicht wirklich ein praktikum ich behalte meinen alten job ich bleibe
in meinem alten team aber ich gucke mir halt mal was anderes an
weil es mich interessiert was sie da so machen
okay jetzt end angle oder so ja zack zack ich hoffe mal dass funzen java
genauso dann nehmen wir uns nämlich dieses ganze ding hier packen das hier
rein und jetzt returnen wir
jetzt muss ich sagen exception hat er da oben okay und jetzt returnen wir return
was macht man damit jetzt und mit output nein nein nein nein ich will das doch
nicht gar nicht reiten ich will das gar nicht reiten
ich will output image ich will das als beide ray wie kriege ich denn das hier
als beide ray output image ist das vielleicht schon beide ray get data
Ich brauche hier irgendwas.
Byte Array.
Ja genau, da Stack Overflow regelt.
Ba-O-A-O-A, das kann ich mal aussprechen.
Alter was?
Ba-O-S.
Ach das hat er einfach so genannt, ich dachte das heißt New Byte Array Output Stream.
und dann sagt man ach so ok verstehe
und jetzt sagen wir hier
baus ne schnitt einfach noch so und das können wir jetzt hier
to buy the rey schon hammer und sie es fakt methode
png richtig alles klar
Was hat er hier eigentlich zu merken?
Was schlägt IntelliJ denn vor?
Cast to Double.
Macht er das unter der Haube nicht eh schon?
Warum soll ich das extra nochmal casten?
Kegweight HD XD.
wenn er meint
so haben wir hier das bild das wird wird es mit 90 grad gedreht gut also jetzt
kann man sagen das heißt es übrigens heißt es da auch so generate image sagen
90 grad was was was merken return value ist never used ist alles ich halte jetzt
sei man nicht so anstrengend java und jetzt aber wir können eigentlich im prinzip können
wir das hier sagen so schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funzt das kackt bestimmt ab es geht es
geht. Hacker meinen Modus aktiviert, Leute. Es funzt. Easy.
Ja gut
So und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie random
Also jetzt müssen wir noch randomisen
Also wir brauchen jetzt zwei Fälle
Wenn hier
Ein Name übergeben wird oder kein Name
Wenn hier noch ein Parameter
Übergeben wird
roten wir wie es im parameter steht wenn kein parameter übergeben wird dann wird randomized
gucken ob das ob das irgendwie funktioniert wir random eisen das jetzt erst einmal hier random
Jetzt.
Was?
Chump-Able-Generator.
Leap-Able-Generator.
Ah, yes.
Exquisite.
Math.random ist das Richtige hier.
Ah, ne Moment.
Ach so.
Na, eigentlich will ich das nicht.
Kann man hier Limit oder so eingeben?
Ne, auch nicht, oder?
Oh, was?
D-Compiler?
Ich wollte mir eigentlich nur anzeigen lassen, was es da für...
Ähm, ja, okay.
Java, generate random
in between range.
also diese play-on seite die scheint sich gut mit java aus und
anders geht es nicht wirklich nicht
dass das finde ich jetzt aber ganz abgedreht java util random next int ja
Ja, das will ich haben. Das ist gut.
Moment, warum ist next in
max minus min
plus min?
Warum ist das denn so eklig gemacht?
Also so basic
sieht Java gar nicht mehr aus.
In stream.
Ach, da
kann man jetzt min und max eingeben
oder was?
Wie viele Random
Generators gibt es denn jetzt hier eigentlich noch?
Es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Es hört wirklich nicht mehr auf.
also am besten muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen gefällt mir das hier red local random was es
bei mir gar nicht gibt doch korinth next in origin
also quasi from two wieso java weil die bei uns auf der arbeit alles mit java
programmieren also von null bis 360 wobei das eigentlich von 1 bis 360 weil
wobei 360 macht eigentlich auch kein ist das inklusive nee das ist exklusive also
es geht dann bis 359 also von null bis 359
so
So, okay.
Jetzt müsst ihr jetzt, jetzt müsst ihr jetzt
funzen. Jetzt müsst das Bild random
rotaten, wenn du das richtig, richtig
funzt. Ha! Leute!
Random KQW-Rotation.
Aber die Qualität des Rotatens ist nicht gut
Guckt mal, wie schlecht das Bild
Guckt mal, wie schlecht das Bild rotated ist
Alter
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ja hässlich wie die Nacht
übrigens kein anti leasing ja trotzdem alles das ist ja wirklich das ist nur
Ich meine, aber es macht jetzt immer prinzipiell das, was es soll.
Es rotiert das Image.
So, und jetzt ist die nächste Frage.
Wie kriegen wir das hin,
dass man ein Parameter übergeben könnte?
Ich will ja nicht wirklich ein Parameter.
ich will also ich will es ja so angeben können also ich will sagen können was ich will meine
güte alter pistisch google kann man das ausblenden image search das faktisch ab das muss weg
ich will ja sowas hier angeben können slash 1 zum beispiel gleich zwei ist gleich drei und dann soll
das machen aber das ist dann also ich will ich will im prinzip so was hier haben
war variable
ok
schon wieder mal play um
ach so funzt es ja das ist gut warum es auch immer ein string ist so will ich das haben ja genau
string kann man dem gleich sagen bitte einmal in int konvertieren oder ja checkt er das so
Wir wollen das mal aus.
Mal gucken, ob er das gleich richtig
convertet. Achso, ja gut.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Ja.
Ja, so toll finde ich das mit den Annotations
auch nicht.
Achso, weil ich hier...
Genau.
Ja, trotzdem nicht.
Not found.
Aha, ich hab's doch richtig gemacht.
Was soll eigentlich dieses Response Buddy die ganze Zeit?
Das hab ich hier gar nicht drin stehen.
Hier braucht man ID.
So, hä?
so also ok
so und jetzt würde ich gerne gucken kann man dem ding in den defaults
denn die falls irgendwie setzen oder was gibt es sonst noch so
consumes produce heather params path value weil das ding ist
ach nee ich musste ich muss das zweimal machen ich brauche es einmal so und ich brauche einmal ohne
einmal komplett ohne und da wird jetzt hier random gemacht und sonst wird hier einfach das getönt
Oh, er muss doch funzen jetzt.
Normalerweise gibt man
ein Response Entity zurück.
Und
Aber
wie jetzt?
Also den verstehe ich immer noch nicht.
Warum ich da Response Body
hinschreiben soll.
Weil ich gebe ja hier einfach nur Bytes
bytes zurück quasi als image png
schauen wir mal ob das funzt wenn ich da jetzt reinschreibe 740 dann klappt das
so wenn ich nichts reinschreibe dann wird random rotated so ist das gut
Das ist gut.
Das ist nice.
Jetzt chatte es von uns.
Keck WS Service.
In Java.
Mit dieser super übersichtlichen
Bildkreisdrehmethode.
Jetzt natürlich die nächste Frage.
Jetzt habe ich
eine Basic Java Anwendung.
Wie würde ich die jetzt denn bilden?
Also, kann man in Java
irgendeine Self-Contained Anwendung bilden?
Geht das?
Wenn ich sowas sage wie...
Also, im Prinzip sowas wie...
Minus Minus Self-Contained in .NET oder so,
dass der Java mit einpackt.
ich habe einen maven maven target für bild ja habe ich hier guck mal da irgendwo life cycles
ich habe clean validate compile test package install verify
ja und in docker na ich wollte mal gucken ob das so generieren kann
geht nicht also irgendwo selbst content binary was dann da rauskommt es gibt es nicht oder
denn ja weil brauche ich immer noch java ich will irgend so ein self content binary
wo ich einfach starten kann will ja kein container aber wahrscheinlich geht das nur
mit extra extra wurscht
was mir anja nicht bei edu brauchst immer noch java dafür ich habe gedacht
vielleicht gibt es die möglichkeit dass man eine anwendung generiert weil einfach
einen binary rausfällen dass ich starten kann ohne dass java installieren muss
vorher
So wie man das bei .NET macht, wenn man "-selfcontain angibt, der bundelt die komplette .NET Runtime zusammen und zippt das zusammen in den Binary.
Dann kannst du starten und er packt das im Hintergrund aus und startet dann mit der Embedded Runtime das eigentliche Programm.
native image hat
aha
das ist glaube ich für mich noch
das ist für mich zu etwas aller
ja ich weiß das wollte ich ja nicht vielleicht geht das irgendwie ein fläche
singen wie eingebaut habe ich gedacht es ist nicht also container image kriege ich
da schon noch gebaut das ist kein ding das ist aber auch nicht ziel von dem stream so
So, Chat, habt ihr eine Idee, was wir noch einbauen können?
So ein bisschen mehr üben wäre schon nicht verkehrt,
weil wirklich großartig gemacht haben wir jetzt ja noch gar nichts.
Was könnte...
Vielleicht...
Lass doch mal kurz gucken.
Kann man vielleicht...
Java Rotate Image mit Anti-Aliasing.
Image soll aus der Datenbank geladen werden.
Boah!
Datenbank-Integration. Das könnten wir tatsächlich
machen.
Nee, Datenbank finde ich ganz, Datenbank
finde ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll. Wir starten
irgendeine Postgres-Docker
und gucken mal, ob wir da irgendwas reinschreiben
können. Wobei, dann müssen wir
uns, wenn wir das machen, oh, das,
nee, dann machen wir ein komplett neues
Fass auf. Dann müssen wir uns dann mit irgendwelchen
ORM-Mappern
und Zeug beschäftigen. Ich glaube, das schafft
mein Hirn heutzutage jetzt gerade nicht.
Kannst auch Liquibase, was ist Liquibase?
Wie macht er das jetzt?
Ah, hier?
Ne.
Äh.
Und woher weißt du jetzt, dass man da Interpolation macht?
Durch das hier.
1, 1, 0.
Da weißt du ja auch sofort Bescheid, was gemeint ist.
Das ist eigentlich...
Nee, Start ist das.
Image Observer.
Observer Factory.
Singleton.
Observer.
Wo macht er das hier?
Ich check es halt, wie macht er das so hier?
Und dann?
dann wird das anti elast oder was macht das jetzt einfach mal ohne dass ich verstehen würde
checke nicht was ich da mache aber vielleicht ist es jetzt anti elast
oder muss ich new
an der chat weiß bescheid okay ich mache das was der chat geschrieben hat
okay das funktioniert
aber ich mache das macht es ja auch komplett falsch war das mal schon input image
checks kann ich muss das hier
okay chat sagt g2d set set rendering hint und dann was rendering hins alles jetzt aber
eklig rendering hinz anti alias on aha
nicht wirklich oder
sieht immer noch eklig aus wo man das vielleicht irgendwie davor machen
dann nicht dann bleibt es da bleibt das bild jetzt so hässlich ist auch okay
dann bleibt es so
hier machen sie auch so was guck
aha
die machen dann noch mehr
Machen wir auch. Wir copy-pasten von Stack auf auf Low, so wie sich das gehört.
Sieht immer noch genauso hässlich aus.
Sieht das jetzt besser aus? Nee, oder? Nee, das sieht auch genauso hässlich aus.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob man das auch machen kann.
Ich habe mir das copy-pasted von irgendwo.
Ne, ne.
Das bleibt jetzt so.
Das sieht halt hässlich aus beim Rotaten.
Meinetwegen.
So.
Chat, mein Gehirn reicht.
meinem gehirn reicht für heute mit java als eineinhalb stunden java stellt ich
habe gelernt wie man das bringt anwendung erstellt warum ein intelligent
richtig funktioniert habe ich immer noch nicht verstanden
das reicht für heute an java stellt genug
immerhin weil großartig kompliziert ist es nicht da muss man auch erstmal drauf kommen
ich glaube ich gehe jetzt noch mal an die frische luft
oder würde ich sagen wir hören uns leute bis dann macht's gut